[Music]
Rob Mary did you know how easy it is to
make an MMO supposedly it's just not
difficult at all I I've never imagin
before with all those complaining devs
right that it actually is super easy and
you can turn it out in like a day bunch
of winers I know uh it turns out that
Goat Simulator has an MMO and that's
what we are playing today it looks
brilliant it looks great already um we
have only played about how many minutes
so far about four about four minutes so
uh this is pretty open for us in an open
world we're going into this vast World
blind and I'm really excited for what
we're going to find out cuz it's already
pretty ridiculous it is pretty
ridiculous so yeah let let's Dive Right
In um let's take a look at these classes
here yeah I think that's the first thing
in anmos you got to pick the right class
right or your your entire game is going
to be messed up right Hunter as you can
see there let's see yeah we got right
being well versed with the survival of
the fittest Hunters desire not the
Comforts of cities but to seek the
unforgiving Wilds masters of forests and
rivers Hunters stalk upon their prey
using their sharp metal lures to trap
and catch all kinds of animals
everything from trout to Salmon so many
different types you have a little you
got your I think that's my favorite
already I mean it's pretty good you
ready to go fishing uh yeah all right
that's pretty strong Let's see we got a
rogue cool standard that's a standard
MMO tank that's the beastly one he looks
great he's got blood hanging off all his
tusks he has seen some
[__] we got the magician class lesser
popular in MMOs but nevertheless uh
Hunters stun ping their prey using sharp
metal lures I believe that this is the
hunter class let's go to the magician
let's see
all kinds of energies and spells such as
card decks a hat with a hidden
Department in it and a plastic wand life
is never the same again today 30 years
later The Magicians have spent many
hours in many hours of practice in their
parents or parents
basement they can now pull off the
perfect card trick and their perception
is so Keen it always finds nickel behind
people's ears I bet you start off with a
little bit more money yeah probably uh
and then there's no class you don't need
I don't need nothing you're a big boring
person you get the power of goat uh life
achievements include going into space
becoming a demon flying a jetpack and
being the queen of all goats all good
all great all right and then and
then microwave the microwaves are the
most evil constructs in both this world
and the next they are pure Chao chaotic
evil alignment look at those terrifying
legs coming out of them something out of
like a dream it's horrifying that is the
weirdest thing one day the microwaves
will consume both the living and the
dead well I don't know if we should
start with the microwave I think we
should start with one of the other ones
and maybe come back in I'd like to be a
magician I think yeah that looks pretty
do you have any strong feeling no
magician looks great I like that Top Hat
what are
these shoulder
pants let's do it give it a whirl go oh
right off the dead pile of
goats I'm not
dead I'm feeling up yes you are oh
what's going on over here I'll try
licking
him oh yeah it's going really well Gary
got him by the foot can I all right and
off I go and your tongue is
insane here we go so the one of the
first things we noticed is that the chat
is killer assassin there's a chat in the
bottom left there as you can see and
it's it's popping there are so many
people playing this
game press one to save to
inventory so let oh I made how' you do
that
just cards how you do that I just
there's no Rhyme or Reason I think I
just hit one oh
soda M I will take that take
it so is that how do you take everything
by Fanning out the
cards that's not going to get old um
yeah so one is putting things in your
inventory all right how do I talk to
Greta oh wait I did it you happen to
have I oh that was easy I leveled up I
am ready for I unlocked armor all right
let's put this on got a cousin who's in
some deep [__] he owns a farm just north
of here you'll recognize him by the
distressed look on his face all right
let's do that you ready for real okay so
North so should I travel up north north
well pull out your map all right I
assume you'd think it's m but it's
Escape so if I go
north I can probably find her cousin
around here or maybe near goat Shire so
if you guys can't see yeah there's a
bunch of um oh we didn't see these areas
before on the left there's yeah there's
goat Shire there's a jousting tournament
we have to uh definitely venture
to but um there's so many good things
yeah so just I would say just North look
at there's looks like a little crop Farm
area I have skills here so one is my
card trick but I also have
R
um left Mouse is my headbutt I want to
try R and see what that's all about that
looks like a magical skill um s and my
left Mouse does something and then
that's a Sprint that's like a
um a uh like a dash forward Ram okay
good to know let's try R uh we'll also
go north so um R
right oh look at that I killed
myself I'm all right I'm all right can I
add him to my inventory I'll just oh
he's okay no you did he's in your
inventory all right bring him along here
we go come with
us Slayer of
cows right he doesn't want to
come this is
ridiculous whoa nice jump oh there's a f
I think you landed directly right in the
farm this guy is I think that's the
cousin that's seen some [__] this guy
has got the moves right here all right
talk to me man oh wait I'm supposed to
collect apples for this dude I think
maybe yep last time it was a
soda I really enjoy my card tricks yeah
that's good you truly saved my life
these words aren't enough to express my
gratitude you really need your help hey
Steve Works wait what did he give me you
you completed it I think you
automatically did it I thought he was
going to give me oh I'm sorry man sorry
dude I'll put him in my inventory oh my
God that
scream c car is so ridiculous
what's her
name Mia
klock of course that's a good attempt I
like that thank you I could not have
done that uh all right here we go all
right where should we go now there's uh
an exclamation mark Over Yonder right
here oh this is him this is you can tell
by the look on his
face you got to help me I've been stuck
in this [__] pile for days now he's just
stuck in a pile of dog [__] he said he
had to eat it to to
survive how do I get him out maybe I'll
lick it oh you did E that is gross I'll
save this [__] to my inventory oh my god
oh I think I might have killed
him I received one piece of
[__] I've been stuck in this [__] pile
for days now well I think we should
conquer more quests and keep leveling up
does it say what level I am I'd love to
know um here's our Quest here so far
that we've already
completed just knocking them out help
the distressed cousin out of the Poo
prison uh if we keep going we'll get to
Goat Shire there's some quests up there
so let's let's continue our journey this
is already the most absurd game I think
I've ever
played tell me if you see anything good
in the chat the chat one says uh when do
you think the next patch will
be uh laugh out loud I didn't know you
could invite friends on on Steam into
this
no the silliest thing all these fake
fresh fruit get your fruit here oh [__]
your
fruit moldy
bread oh no I feel like I can kill
people I'm a little op Teen
Wolf oh that's a you stuck I'll help
you oh no wait oh no oh no oh no
uh-oh oh yeah I didn't think this
through so let's see I didn't even touch
that guy no she's just
tired all what we got over here is there
Quest over here um oh that's a back kick
that's what that is oh never
mind people like to just pass out he
just rammed right into me stop
it oh
okay all right so where I'm looking for
so you there's something is there a
building you can get up looks like
there's one in this building all right
oh here we go there you go I've brought
you
this sacrificial dude he says I'm I'm
super hungry all I have is a can of
spam you look for my oh wait here we
go
I probably the sheep sheep are thieves I
tell you talk about
sheep I also hurry back before my wife
comes all right so I need
to I guess we'll just maybe we'll run
into a sheep
somewhere uh obtain we can get a bunch
of quests at once that's kind of the MMO
way Stairway to your yeah up there let's
go up
here Johnny kind of want to look at my
face oh your eyes are
little weird
come what's up with
my I have no pupils I look like so evil
Johnny is hip hey feel like having a
snack right now could you go fetch me
some things first off I need a package
of butter you should be a voice actor
should I both Knights and elves love
that stuff check with them please hurry
I'm Johnny they make they make it look
so important that you give people this
butter that's also I just like how so
far I've seen just this one dance move
and it's probably the lamest dance move
ever I also think that's very
MMO oh they've
really they've really done a great job
of capturing the essence of what makes a
good MMO my shoes are so stupid was
about to say that we have not talked
about how amazing your shoes are have
you seen like there are like those old
loafers that hook up up in the front I
look like a complete idiot how they are
holding on to your clothes oh nice one
oh good job s good jump Al so I think
someone in the chat said they wanted you
to swim and it looks great swimming is
very well done this is what it looks
like when I
swim people in the chat the real chat
are uh saying it it's better than wow it
is this is the wow killer people have
been waiting for I couldn't agree
more this is oh Doos do I thought those
were
extinct are they yeah they are Dragon
fangs says how do I get a
girlfriend OMG shut up gold
Farmers sorry dude sorry take
them I I procured him all right let's
try some
uhoh uhoh oh is he coming after me you
want to fight with me cuz I got magic he
is on
fire now you're on fire oh no I'm on
fire I'm on fire no no go water I'm
going run do you even you don't even
have like any health or anything like
that shouldn't even be a concern okay
but you put it out made
it those shoes how are those shoes
holding on your h
all right go what it look like when I
jump in the air oh what's that over
there on the right like spin
wheel no you got it put a left little
bit where are we looking here put a left
what the hell is that oh I it looks like
hamster wheel out my way
dodo it looks like a hamster wheel you
can Sprint isn't there like a maybe
whole this a training facility oh look
at
this all right I'm in it I'm in it wait
what's happening oh oh no oh
no oh no I fell
out that was
great it's like a a wheel what the hell
is this in the farm it must be well he
did it you did that is this another Farm
flute
Ken there's like some kind of weird
tractor such a vast world oh here we go
so we're in Goat Shire again
this is where we were I think she is
standing on the table yeah oh my God I'm
so op what a jump
I get out of my
way fresh food just on top
now did any of these guys want lettuce
or bread or did he just want cheese I
don't know cuz I could definite he
wanted an well one guy wanted an opener
for his what was it what's in my spam
how do I pull up my inventory there we
go should I give that guy some [__] see
what he does yeah he put He wants an oer
though I don't know if it's going to
work he's very particular with what he
needs all right
Johnny um use your mouse oh there you go
sh give him some give him some [__] drop
item
one
that noise I just covered him and I just
put poop on him no reaction did you did
you Danny was told me the other day that
I didn't notice that the guys who
created this game literally like paid I
don't know $100 for this goat model like
they didn't like they didn't make it
they didn't make it they just bought it
somewhere for like really
cheap
oh hor SE I did yeah where's he running
to probably in circles oh oh oh I think
he just killed himself whoa you got 10
XP out of it that was really
dark is he okay thank God I'm an expert
swimmer I'll come try to find him I
think we just I think we just watched
the horse ask
himself this chat is so good does anyone
want to marry me
ay you should join my
guild the Sheep Quest is pretty hard
though it is that's the one we're stuck
on lookit there's a guy stuck in a tree
oh look at that what's this can I have
it well oh my God look at this dance
party though on the beach I love that
dance move what am I doing can I have
this oh
oh give me this
I don't think you
can you just look like you just what's
with that
Golds I think it might just be a light
source I think it's just for visual
effect this guy's crawling hey Josh it's
Josh what's hey girl
hey come crawl over here what's she
doing is
she she's like a Roomba she's just
hitting walls and moving over slightly
or she thinks she's a
goat oh my gosh it's
like what kind of sanctuary is this I
don't know she is
weird oh you you saved a sofa well
what's done there there's a little
exclamation mark over here's this dude
what does he want I brought you a
pillow oh some Doo
oh save them bring them to the magic
circle close to the Sheep artillery
nothing goes extinct on our watch so the
Doos we saw earlier were supposed to
bring to here so you weren't supposed to
kill them well I think
I that's that was terrifying oh that was
weird looking what was he doing the worm
I don't
know oh my
God
that guy's running on all
Bo what's
happening around chicken
no God this is weird I'm going to dream
about this tonight wake up screaming the
guy running around like a oh no they
just fall over they're like those sheep
that get scared and pass out all right
there they go they're back up oh
oh
oh I I think that's one of the most
terrifying things yeah that's that's
going to be burned in my head hey kill
this Dark Assassin all
right have some M oh oh he is he can't
cross have some magic he's probably got
a high ping
they're going to fix you know that's you
know that's like
intentional they're going to fix that in
the next patch so
stupid all right so you want to go get
some dos Doos doo birds one guy yeah do
that one guy in the chat says can you
turn off the
chat butter oh butter did he want oh
yeah we did want butter did he he wanted
it right yeah he did good call good call
all right how do I oh don't lose it I
don't want that chair I don't want that
chair I want this
butter save butter to inventory and then
I Make It Rain some cards oh what's on
the bed here I think that's giraff head
a giraffe head I should probably keep
that oh you leveled up what level are
you oh five it says save goat to
inventory cuz you can play as a goat and
one the other ones I just want everyone
see how amazing that
looks yeah [__] I'm a magic man I'll
makeing rain
cards you sorry
ass
oh all right so we got butter and now we
need some do dodo birds so let's go find
some dodo birds well I'm glad we're
finding all right so we're actually
progressing feels good to level up it
does you should um yeah you should do
these two quests and I say you try out
the jousting tournament all right I'm
kidding I'm getting lost here I think I
wa it's blue I think I this is night and
now it's day I think
it's the blue from the water oh carries
over yeah that's probably it it's hard
to tell though because MMOs do change
from night to day you going you're going
the wrong way oh no uh go back we need
that too that guy need the opener for um
all right the durge durge I I've never
heard of that before durge it's like a
um
yeah dge dge one one so where the hell
am I I'm at the very end of the world
here so I need to crawl back up can't
believe it took like that long they
really should make fast travel they
should should I just crawl up River
yeah here we
go what this guy need no he he need Doos
so we can get
those all right I think it's this way
yep following the map in the upper right
corner okay you're getting 10 XP for
what just running I think I got it for
like jumping oh nice move thanks um I
have leveled up really
fast oh this is the Doos right are they
over here uh yeah this is the horse that
kills himself oh oh let's let's see if
he does he just kills himself every time
like oh my God the water and axes
himself all right
so all right dodo
acquired um
now that guy said that the goats were
stealing food did he want me to kill the
goats or there's maybe um oh is he
attack he is attacking me they're higher
they're a little higher level oh are
they how many Doos do I
need such a terrifying noise scream come
here
dodo I'm trying to keep you from going
extinct idiot this is why they go
extinct they're like pandas they're too
stupid they're way stupid everybody
wants them to be saved but the reality
is is that if you don't want to save
yourself what could I possibly do for
you how many Doos I got four no I got
five I'm good oh he said five yeah we
got enough oh cool I think that's what
he always oh there's a guy in the
waterfall there there's a man in the
waterfall how
mysterious someone just fell off I wish
I could look up without going underwat
oh my God this swimming is amazing it's
perfect he must want to oh look there's
a guy up there oh there's a bull he
probably threw that person
off he just staring in a wall I'll God
you are so good at jumping thank
you oh no oh technically I'll hide the
body in your goat body he'll
just he'll be fine graceful
s
XP I suppose all right all right go back
to Goat Shire okay oh this servant needs
help let's see what he
needs hello servant oh cool dance move
haven't seen that part what do you need
what do you need
baby what kind of
situation oh is it is it the guy we just
saw yeah need need that money
honey does that what if we killed him
for this money I wonder if it's that guy
we
saw let me climb this I see a guy up
there see him there he is how do I get
up there you could probably your jump is
pretty insane all right here we
go oh damn you almost had that oh there
stairs there I don't think they go to
the top though I think they go oh you
can get up there oh you got this easy
luckily I'm a
goat what's up
nerd bet you're not good enough to do
what bet you're not good enough to what
he
say oh to dive from
here he wants you to dive oh he wants
you to dive in the water he betting me
yeah he bets so you just jump off that's
why the the other dude jumped off you
just jump off of there do
it I'm I'm so cool your feet are
flopping Goen up show that bully the
trick with bullies that a lot of people
don't know is that if you do what they
dare you you earn their respect right my
ass is just fully in the
air sick pose yeah I mean if there was a
gif that summarizes game I think it
might
be that I think you can zoom in with the
mouse wheel
yeah I close up that goat
pose it looks great now let's
swim I'm
swimming can you believe it's such a
good
MMO
best you know this came out in 2014 so
it's still eligible for Game of the Year
you know what it's got my vote let's go
check out suicide horse said can you
ride on that horse I highly doubt it
give a shot so he's not we're not going
to make it before he kills himself he
just kind of kills himself but there
should be another one
spawning this vast
world is so beautiful oh there's the
music is pretty cool can we Tri the
music a little bit it's
like the suicide horse should oh here we
go he just here we go shows up here here
we go time it right
oh no close oh you got it I'm such a
good jumper I
can't I
jump just responds and kills himself
Kenny Kenny's not doing too good it's
really it's really hard to control my
extremely strong
jumps I thought I saw a exclamation mark
over here maybe what's these ex all
right I'm G to try this one more time
some guy in the game chat says
I don't think you can ride him very well
says I can't believe they they actually
patched in MMO support and someone says
laugh out loud yeah I know right it took
pretty long several months so much
development so much time what's that oh
that's a Golden Goat you didn't want
that oh I found a Golden Goat one of 20
what is going on oh I look up what the
hell's happening something's falling
whoa oh you were getting on that
um all right did it give me negative
XP I'm
get wait it's really hard to jump
because it's so I I I go way too far go
limp all
right
go someone in the chat in the game says
mom get out of the game
please Mom all right let me try one more
time it didn't work very oh jeez oh you
see that over to the right it's like
a like a satanic
worship
yeah yeah yeah on here how do I worship
Satan do some moves do you
magic who do uh do the cards
um I call upon you Satan if that scream
doesn't hell say none else can I
licking there must be you know what what
if it requires a sacrifice let's go into
our in inventory and offer it something
we could offer
it a goat this guy do
that we are oh he just walks away damn
it okay let's try again um what else can
we offer
him a
sofa I'll give him another a
donkey this isn't going to
work accept my sacrifices oh mighty oh
oh oh oh oh
oh all right now we're going have to
figure that out later I think that's
like a maybe like a later Quest all
right if you think I'm done here go um
go back to Gold CH or gold CH goat CH
and finish up some uh I'm going to go
the fastest way possible wish you could
actually launch off this didn't look
like you
could you have to believe that's the
secret I'm level five already I'm so
good
launch that is pretty
impressive
oh man they'll probably fix that in the
next p they'll fix
that um looks like there's a quest over
there should we turn anything in what do
you want to do I think you should finish
up some quests level up what you know
what can we put stuff in there what if I
oh yeah put something in there put some
uh I feel like we haven't exhausted all
the possibilities here I think I have
some poop you do you're your guid right
there do
it
get
out oh yeah where did it it's gone did I
fling just flung [__] somewhere in the
world there's that horse again oh murder
horse all right my sacrifices don't seem
to be doing much we'll we'll check back
on that
later it looks like there is a quest
over here so I'm just going to check it
out real fast
so many quests General sergeant
lieutenant maggot the battle plan is the
following called you
maggot sheep
Village all right use the stealth device
to infiltrate my sheep the Sheep Village
all right I assume it's this is he
teaching me how to use
it he didn't give anything guess is it
maybe now I can be flung
oh goats can fly oh my God I'm going
over it I'm going to break the game
those sheep will never know what hit
them I'm so [__] oh no I'm So Far Away
what an [__] you overshot it I
did I'm so
far swimming is so good I
know where am I
going I'm a lot faster when I'm Airborne
so I just keep bobbing up and
down oh my God are we back where we were
before no these are different people
yeah the this is this has got to be uh
well we're in twist Ram twist
Ram maybe this is sheep
Village or is it Ram Village Reaper claw
Dumbledore the gray mhm oh no what a
jerk I've been trying to open a portal
to the land of gold but I lack a single
crucial ingredient a demonic horn can
you venture into oh that [__] Old Goat
Mountain and get me one I'm going to
kill this son of a
be oh I'm getting this level might be
too high area
SC screw that
dude whoa I'm just dropping mad bombs
whoa
whoa shouldn't have messed with the
magician that was your mistake oh you're
low yeah oh yeah get him this is this is
when you oh yeah take
that sometimes you just got to Crunch on
the game a little bit and level up
enough so that you can take on higher
monsters this is the grind this is the
oh uhoh oh no uhoh I'm through the here
I'm back totally intentional I'm back
far the game I'm raining bombs on
this oh how do you keep doing that I
don't there's no Rhyme or Reason oh nice
aerial attack you can't kill good call
you can't kill me peasants all right oh
all right I got to get out of here yeah
you got to get out here I'm breaking it
whoa yeah I'll land there thanks just
float
around you thought you could kill me
snipe him I don't think I have any
skills in which to do
that is your Fireball directional at all
is just what it doesn't appear as if I
have any control over
it so suck at
losers kill all of
you take that Reaper claw lose it yeah
you were leveling up look at all this XP
I'm doing nothing I'm at level seven
already I wonder what the cap is we're
going to have to do um a guide to how to
level up I think so the guide is to
perch really high and murder all those
stupid
noobs um all
right where do you want to go uh the
chat in the game says anybody else
getting really bad rubber banding issues
oh my guy fell right into my
goat he said don't be shy come right up
step right on up don't be shy is this to
kill
yourself yeah try it oh my God that guy
just I don't think you can kill kill
yourself look at him he's on fire
Thomas feel like an authentic witch all
right as we've learned from
earlier you always do what bullies tell
you to do am I on fire mhm
success oh wait I lost
it I'd like to keep my
fire um I'm on fire
go check your map can I light this guy
yeah Emily I like how like the names
don't really match up with like the
gender at all like I
seen just random like Joshua is a girl
Emily is a guy what's on fire over here
a random
goat idiot you're on fire
stupid all right you should finish some
quests go to go to Gold CH God saying
gold CH goat CH all right let's find it
on our map where are we at here so make
a make go right yeah finish this Quest
all right let's do
it
right oh it's right here this is go CH
isn't it yeah just follow this path here
we are what is
that gold Harvest Golem is a weird
looking thing I
get can I oh nice work broke it broke it
sorry it didn't have a lot of HP for how
big seems like everything I could pretty
much oh I think I
know is this launching oh you will be
launched on
this go
oh I got to get in it can you get more
forward jumping is so
perfect it's just launching pumpk I
think that's what I was getting hit with
earlier yeah was the pumpkin
launcher where's so many ridiculous
things in this game all right all right
go back to Goat CH I think it's really
easily to get it's easy to get
distracted in any good MMO it is that's
that's very
true I would say that I Verge on being
chaotic evil more than anything mhm oh
oh was this dude he talk to I hate that
beekeeper when I met him at the market
the other day he called me a nerd I got
to get revenge could you wreck his
beehives I can do that man oh I'm sorry
dude you'll be fine I'm too
op all right so I know I have butter so
where was that guy that um this guy is
one I think he was the spam dude you
have that oh up up up your shoes are
giving you a hard
time there you go what Tak you so long I
was about to die from Hunger anyway
thanks I wonder where my wife is though
she's she doesn't care about you I'm
getting stuck what a great
backstory everyone's giving a lot of
credit to dragon souls Inquisition but I
really think that they put a lot of
effort into the character
creation I'm having trouble
walking jump oh whoa yeah what's going
on here I don't
know okay all
right go uh go limp okay and maybe you
can
reset May that does
something I feel like the world doesn't
like what's happening this is probably
part of the
game this is probably what happens when
you when you hit level eight maybe this
is my
new Talent is that I can do
this I'd really like to get up there and
give that guy butter but he
doesn't I just want to get through
that let me get in
there there's something wrong with the
world uh this game's broken
dude in the best way oh oh
I mean how can you say that it's clearly
fine I'm just certain things just not
happy with all right I'm sick of this
bully F you bully I hate
bullies take that where's the other dude
there was so many
quests I think they turn into question
marks so this is the only one that I
think we
can
technically we didn't
even get the infiltration Quest because
he shot us so freaking far that we
didn't get
it a do uh try to do the Jing tournament
I Haven even done that
yet zero out of 10 lazy devs in the chat
which one do you want to do you butt hat
who says
that it's PC the
um Jing so go straight go dead straight
there's like a jing
tournament sounds promising yeah I think
we can't go Noah you
lazy kick him off wake up you're dead
wake up you're
dead he's on
fire he's sleeping on
fire this oh it's such a beautiful day a
little hot but I mean it's pretty good
all right to the Jou to the Jou to the
Jou I think oh so it's up on this hill
to the
left oh that is oh this is going to be
great that is a jousting
tournament that's my stopping animation
is that with your is that with your butt
yeah sick all right
Christian I lost my bail my parents are
going to go crazy can you help me find
another one a baale like a like
Christian baale like a I go
bucket his name's Christian
Wayne oh butter butter so there's
more maybe maybe the guy needed more
butter I'll take I got [__] I got so
much
butter spam this
wo oh my God
magic do you think anyone else is
impressed with that like if I saw let me
see if I can please the king how you
Jou it might just be an area
[__]
dude aren't you impressed with this
king's
weather gu's a jerk no there's no
interest
he just passed
out all
right dude got a quest right
here suicide
horse oh I got you
man fixed
oh
whoa what is that it's a Troublesome
stick
whoa you repaired it looks repaired good
job you're
welcome follow me I'll get you where you
need to
go put them in my
inventory feel these
buttheads
they oh isn't that like a something I
need is it no that's what they were
launching on the Catapult oh no
uhoh uh no it's part of the game whoa
you're going through like a
wormhole no oh I'm back
[__] is this so this is this is
snowflake this is weird this is where
they make dead
goats get up you stuck go limp I am I am
stuck oh there you go all right go lip
on be
dead oh gross
gross
I'm just a dead
goat just like the rest of them here I
go there's so many physics
right here we
go what's this machine what kind of
device is this that just pumps out dead
goats every [__] 2 minutes every town
need needs one it's it's important to
have a dead goat
maker oh what are you pushing when you
do that like how does that
happen trying that's what my dog looks
like if you hover it over
water I think a lot of times it's just
like clicking a few buttons at once can
maybe cause it
yeah but if I were to be completely
honest with you I don't think there's a
lot of Rhyme or Reason as to how I can
fall through a
world
damn do you want to try um I actually
kind of want to try the microwave yeah I
was actually going to say that that'd be
a good way to
um end it on all right let's I think
this has gone really well so far I'm
thinking a game of the year
contender
for sure nothing can beat sure for for
sure nothing can beat
this goat MMO here we go and this is
really cool too we didn't show this
earlier but um the loading screen makes
it look like it's
connecting to the servers but it's you
know at the bottom is like it's like
bypassing something and then at one
point it's flashing all these things of
what it's doing and one of them was just
butt connecting to butts
uh all right here we go yeah oh yeah
this is terrifying that walk is pretty
great I have a cord dangling out of my
is that so is that the equivalent to
your tongue out of my ass oh yeah do I
you what are my so one is
[Laughter]
pizza
R is my explosion maybe everyone gets
that oh my God that's the best walk it's
disgusting that's why I'm going to walk
from now
on oh god um what was
explosion oh that's your that's your
melee door opens smack them with the
door my S is my
back that's where I show them what I'm
working with what um what was the
explosion one and E is my tongue doesn't
know if it works R is my explosion I
think it just kills
myself all right
let's my run is
terrifying oh my God here I
come all right
let's I want to see you grab on
something with that
door this guy is rubber banding like
crazy leave him alone there you go oh
it's my cord it is your cord that's
great I just wrap my cord around
them come
here I got
something so stupid do you want to play
as the microwave
sure
go I think we should play I think we
should spend the last few minutes
playing as each character and learning
what their special skills are sure so
but let's let's get more of this
walk oh I like the side steps you look
classy that's terrifying why don't you
run over to another area and see what
else you can get into oh he does like a
cool front
flow he does zo out a little bit front
flip
[Music]
good oh my God S Plus left click I'm
going to maze here to
twerk ooh sword
o so it's e yeah and then one to put in
inventory oops sorry
whoa so no the um the microwave still
has the same sound effect as the goat
it's technically a goat
it is oh the frame dropping frame
dropping they'll fix that in a in a
patch I saw some in the chat say
that is there anywhere else we have oh
wait no see your swim I want to see how
you swim oh okay do we go down oh Ste
one down we what's this beach say I
can't read
thatal Beach let's make let's go there
let's go there have a beach day go have
a beach party they've done such a
beautiful job populating the world it
feels like I'm really there as a
microwave a
microwave feel convinced I know what am
oh am I in chat look I'm in chat they
actually have chat
something how did you get in chat I I I
did enter oh yeah that's standard
standard right also MMO so MMO they got
that
nailed where's the beach again okay on
our way here we
go
this is disgusting will you zoom out a
little bit oh
God you fell into some
daisies excuse
me you automatically flip when you do
jump oh God God that's so like like a
microwave would so do that what's
yours trying to roll into the I guess
this is it
yeah now you're swimming
wow oh there's the horse suicide
horse oh my God I guess we'll just take
this path right
[Music]
yeah I don't even know Andre
fondel
for he probably just mashed the keyboard
let's go
there
that servant still needs his money we
never got it for him lit him on fire
give him a pizza oh that was exactly
what I was going to do here you go was
it again one
one have some
pizzas idiot so
poor keep
going that shot right there that's good
that's good that's good [__] garle
bearle we made it we did it whoa you
found a
mermaid
oh ow kill it kill it with fire use R
Ros
Jesus where's he going shoot pizzas at
it wait no wait go back go back that
guy's talking to you oh what's up you go
out there you kill them kill as many of
them as possible a and take eyes their
lifeless evil staring eyes just make the
sound stop all right you got it kill
those mer oh my
God come
here ew they do make gross noises whoa
oh look at this this other player is
helping me you guys are working together
teamwork online teamwork this explosion
is so ridiculous just explode you just
explode just near people um you have a
butt attack if you back up into them and
hit s and your left click you should hit
them with your
ass yeah
okay yeah twerk them to
[Laughter]
death sit on
him oh these guys want to go oh yeah get
some e this is the most absurd
thing I've ever seen oh God so
beautiful they need some
pizzas are you hungry hey girl are you
hungry
hey got
him you carrying him I feel like the
cord doesn't actually carry them it just
attaches you to them so get the fishee
you need those to complete the quest
right so you need to lick them and then
hit I uh use space to get
up there you go now lick them and hit
one to put it in your
inventory you know like a microwave
that's I is that the fish people that
make that noise no that's
me it's hard to
know this is my nightmare this is a
nightmare kill it ah
you they have a lot of power they do man
this Frame K that guy to the left he's
almost dead I didn't mean to do that
stupid
microwave come here hit space to get up
these visuals are pretty there you go no
every time you get hit you'll have to
hit space to kind of
right this wish then have to explode
away don't hit R just hit them with your
left click seems like a really strong
move use your basic attack
right there you go oh look at
that level
nine you're the best microwave all right
so they're dead they're dead and then
eventually when they burn to death
they'll turn into fish eyes but I would
just take them all down cuz they're
pieces of [__] yeah that's true good job
twerk him
yeah idiot it keeps spawning all
right that's also very
Amo no yeah hit
one there you go so you got two there
should be a bunch more on the ground you
killed a bunch of them it'll say fisheye
above it if you can take
it this microwave thing is
ridiculous take them all out
oh there's a lot of pizzas over there o
pizzer I can't wait to have a pizzer hey
you guys want some pizzza M delicious
pizzza
where that's it I maybe I have to go
somewhere else here's no you need five
right I think I think I depleted the
fisheye in that area all
right there you go two more go back to
there I think you should go back yeah oh
there's one so what happens is after you
kill them I think they have to burn to
death for a second and
get
it no it yeah you know there you go no
you lost it sh get out of here
Merman oh see it I think you destroyed
it on accident oh what yeah but so
there's one get that
fishee no it's it's attaching this other
one there you go and then one more this
is
it yeah now go complete that Quest yeah
we're the best you fish with leg Slayer
I've ever seen I'm going to say I think
the microwave is my favorite these
quests make me
uncomfortable did you break the game I I
personally didn't break the game the
game broke on its own oh no oh no they
need oh there we go all right nice all
you had to do is wait what does he say
that's disgusting here take this reward
are you crazy person ew you make me sick
what an [__] you know
what it hurts you more than it hurts
them does go into that Circle over there
that guy needs help look that guy looks
like he could use a microwave with legs
I'm
[Laughter]
coming let me save you hey Mick slow
pants Adventurer I heard you needed a
microwave no oh damn it I'm afraid
there's you look up I can't really you
saying oh you think you could help me
get there safely oh this is a oh
[Laughter]
slow he's walking so slow that's so
funny males are a bunch of [__] oh
it's so annoying you can help me get
there slow pants Nick slow
pants Oh my
goding so
slow this slowly get in
there hurry
up I just got I'm just talking the
chat oh my God hurry up look at this can
you drag him if you lick him and then
walk him there that is a great idea no
why do you always explode I just really
like that one
you always push got
him speed this up
you
explosion there we go we got it all
right then follow the
path follow the path and just force him
to get
there well I'm not quite sure where he
was going I guess the path path all
right fair enough let's
go we'll see sa you m slow pan well I'll
get you
there is this an incredible time
too look at him freaking out oops
sorry um so here's that there's a fork
here maybe I'll let him go and then see
where he'll let see what direction he
chooses yeah see we're doing it right
look this seriously would take so long
uhoh
keep going down this path until it Forks
again we're really being inventive here
okay you forgot to take him I thought I
had
him
hey I did not light him on fire yes you
did no I did did he combust
yeah that was not my fault I did not
light that guy on fire
okay all right we To
Butthead he'll wake up
[Laughter]
pretty oh my God that's scream oh
no he automat see he automatically
lights on fire I didn't know that
part that's his
special oh my God he walks so slow
you're janking him with
pizzas all right so we picked this
path okay fair
enough make sure you got him okay got
him oh microwave is such a great
class probably one of the better ones
whoops whoops
whoopsies all right where where is he
going where you want to go what if he
doesn't want to go anywhere I want to
finish this dude if he know know it' be
really
great you know be really great if he
like got somewhere he's like oh I forgot
my C keys or something like that like
walks all the way back I would put him
in my
inventory yeah all right he's picked
this path let's take him there clearly
here we go
oops got him you got him he's good
I hear the stupid
horse horse typically wins yeah all
right keep going no oh there's another
Fork
see get up this better be worth like a
million
dollars all right wait he's probably
yeah he's probably going to the
snowflake
dead dead uh goat Factory
thanks I was almost late for work at
this Dead Goat
Factory was he trying to go to work did
he say what he needed I can't remember
we weren't really reading it I'm missing
direct let's see what does oh sorry here
I have the
pizza all right oh
no oh no wait make up your
mind not only is he slow oh look I can
bring my own pizza with me but he's also
an idiot it's so convenient that you can
drag your
own damn it no I didn't mean to do that
I get him yeah do you know where you're
going no I do not oh I remember this is
where he blew up something oh there he
is all right get
up he must be we must be real
[Music]
close
God
oh vomiting pizzas stop drag him P the
poles he's getting stuck on the poles
all right all right he's too
dumb all right he can figure it out from
here once he's not on
fire wake
up he walks dude this would take
probably an hour if you let
him where's he going he went dude he
went literally like the
farthest oh my God's like listen I need
your help protecting me you know nothing
attacked him yeah right he's got full he
just a time he's just the time Quest
where is he
going all right he's going this
way
I knew it what he was looking for
Christian
Bale
yeah oh earlier oh that's right other oh
that's funny it makes sense that's funny
get out of the way get out the way all
right you're not dragging him very far
you're just knocking him
out he might even be slower
walking best Quest
ever
knockout pizzas where is he going where
is there he is oh
yeah yeah oh
yeah no just around the corner with the
mission
name did he say anything to us nothing
nothing is he's walking back now
anything for it unbelievable go in there
to Ariel o I can't stop think stop
thinking about that mermaid I met the
other day her name is Miranda she's so
dreamy but I'm a bit too shy to go see
her again I want to see what she's
saying oh I think she's still at the
beach could you please talk to her maybe
even escort her here so we can get to so
we can be together again I think we
killed
her have some pizza here there's Miranda
oh yeah let's see could do real quick I
think we
should is there anywhere I'd like to see
what the other
um I think we should exit and try
another goat and see what all their
specials are cuz I'm actually really uh
which what each one looks like okay yeah
uh can you restart if you what were you
doing restart no I went to main menu but
try restart and see what that
does oh they can run on walls if you
jump high enough all right I got to load
back
in it's the only problem is sometimes
the load times yeah [__] what what
up buttercup all right let's try this
guy the
tank all right and just try your one
let's see all right let's see they are
one oh so this is this is like the
standard goat this the standard goat
okay
R oh so that's what I was saying we were
doing this earlier so R is like a Sprint
Ram there's Ram one of these guys nice
nice uh what else was there back kick
It's s and yeah there it is he's not
that interesting he's a little Bland
next lfm Uranus
LOL restart all right we'll try another
one What's um
slow-mo slow oh
uh I
forget cuz I'd like to see him do it in
slow mod we didn't do any slow mode that
been
funny try the
Rogue
okay you
got one
oh he's invisible little camo he's
invisible hit
R what's your R do it's just a quick
headbutt quick quick head buddy well
what's your left click then do
oops I guess that's a standard move well
without
S without s yeah what's your click D oh
that is it and then so what's and then R
is the
same I guess R is the same damn
it when you run with this guy does his
head
mind try
this okay yeah all right let's try
somebody
else
what is uh slow-mo I
forget one of them was what is
love but
Buttercup uh
Hunter whoa oh so you know that the the
tongue is going to be the uh press tab
or till and type whoa uh fov to uh space
space hit hit til and then hit f
oov um
space
200 and then enter and then exit til
does that do
anything slow motion all right whatever
it's
SC so he drops a
fish great oh my God look at this you're
such a good fish
look at all these fish I
caught zoom in oh my God it's raining
fish
Hallelujah
R
oh wait what
is you like pick
up the fish I guess is r that you just
dropped so that's really
cool and that's about it pretty good
great pretty good stuff microwave is
still my
favorite no Zoom or um slow-mo is like
hockey it's just like one button I know
it is look like you could go up on all
fours we should be watching those
loading screens it's giving us tips yeah
isn't
it oh that's it
classic
stupid standard stand standard goat
procedure looks like we keep all our
quests which is pretty nice yeah you
just you just continually level up start
will you load it one more time um as
microwave
definitely F slow-mo there it
is um um do
um all right I actually think you should
do yeah we could do pizza but I'd be
cool to do magic cuz I want to see the
cards come out slow mo let's do
that we should have been doing this from
the very beginning we'll just end it on
this
one
yeah yeah
yeah this is good
good absolute
pandemonium what you think I mean I
think you could easily best MMO of the
year so far best I I I would definitely
say that it it's a contender um and I
think it's good that the world knows now
how easy it is to make MMOs yeah it's
just a you know simple as pulling down a
drop menu and just adding it so who knew
I this is great this makes everyone's
job a lot easier it is good thing he
made that public so anyway lots of lots
of fun lots of fun that was good stuff
thanks thanks for going on this weird
Journey with me Rob it was a journey to
be remembered I will never forget
this uh thanks for joining us Goat
Simulator MMO I think comes out tomorrow
tomor so and I think it's is it you just
download it it's like you just download
it it's like a patch as long as you a
goat simulator just go get it and it's
free it's awesome see you guys see you
guys